[Musique]
alors sur TiK ToK on fait on reproche
deux familles assez différentes de
problématiques la première ça va être
tout ce qui est plutôt protection de
l'enfance c'est le temps passé sur
l'application c'est le type de contenu
que voit les enfants et les ados c'est
les challenges un petit peu dangereux
qui peuvent se répandre ça c'est une
première famille la deuxième famille
c'est plutôt la question de la sécurité
et du fait de est-ce que la Chine oui ou
non utilise Tik Tok comme une sorte de
porte cachée une porte dérobée pour
venir espionner pour venir collecter des
données autour des utilisateurs
européens ou américains et plus
largement est-ce que Tik Tok ne serait
pas un instrument soit de soft power
soit d'espionnage à la solde de Pékin
les trois grands piliers de l'Union
européenne donc qui sont la Commission
européenne le Parlement européen et le
Conseil européen ont tous décidé
d'interdire Tik Tok sur les téléphones
de fonction de leur fonctionnaires donc
de leurs employés pourquoi alors les
raisons sont encore un peu floues mais
ils évoquent des problèmes de sécurité
peut-être d'accès aux données enfin ils
ont pas vraiment donné de raison très
très clair mais c'est plutôt le volet
cybersécurité qui les inquiète mais sans
donner en fait de preuve tangibles de de
raison officielle de pourquoi est-ce
qu'ils ont décidé de couper cet accès
ils utilisent le principe de précaution
en 6 ans on n'est pas on n'est pas à
100% sûr de ce qui se passe avec TikTok
donc on préfère mettre à l'abri nos
fonctionnaires en disant si vous
utilisez vos téléphones personnels pour
accéder à votre boîte email
professionnel vous retirez TikTok c'est
un employeur qui dit à ses employés
merci de faire ça sur les appareils que
je vous fournis
pour l'Europe en fait on est dans un
état de droit donc si on veut par
exemple proclamer l'interdiction de Tik
Tok il faut d'abord avoir des preuves
c'est pour ça que actuellement il y a
une enquête qui est en cours au niveau
européen donc c'est au niveau de
l'Irlande donc la CNIL irlandaise le
gardien la protection des doigts des
personnels qui en ce moment entrave
d'enquêter pour justement vérifier la
question centrale qui est est-ce que les
données personnelles des utilisateurs
européens de Tik Tok donc soit vont
jusqu'en Chine mais bon ça a priori
plutôt non la question c'est plutôt
est-ce que depuis la Chine on peut
regarder on peut analyser on peut
examiner des données d'utilisateurs
européens donc ça c'est une enquête qui
en cours qui devrait peut-être aboutir
cette année on l'espère et qu'il a en
fait ça va être à mon avis l'enquête sur
laquelle tout va se reposer ensuite si
la CNIL irlandaise dit bah en fait nous
on la preuve ça va certainement
s'arrêter là par contre si l'acné
l'irlandaise dit ah bah oui quand même
il y a des soucis je pense que avant
d'aller jusqu'à une interdiction TiK ToK
on va plutôt demander à Tik Tok de
prendre des mesures pour empêcher cet
accès depuis la Chine dans le scénario
ou il y aurait des preuves Tangers qui
seraient trouvées plutôt que d'aller
jusqu'à l'interdiction ce sera déjà on
va d'abord demander à l'entreprise
d'agir et si elle ne répond pas à ses
exigences là il pourrait y avoir des
sanctions financières voir des sanctions
administratives pour dire bon bah voilà
on va peut-être vous demander on va
peut-être vous retirer des des magasins
d'applications mais ça va pas se faire
en un claquement de doigts c'est ça
qu'il faut qu'il faut retenir parce que
voilà on est dans un état de droit
Tik Tok est déjà en train de construire
un centre de données en Irlande ils ont
annoncé il y a quelques semaines qui
sont en train d'en construire deux
autres donc au total trois centres de
données en Irlande l'idée étant que
actuellement les données des
utilisateurs européens ne sont pas
stockés en Europe parce que c'est
serveurs n'existent pas encore ils sont
en cours de construction pour le moment
ils sont stockés soit aux États-Unis
soit à Singapour donc déjà rien que ça
en fait par rapport aux règles
européennes autour des données
personnelles ça pose souci donc là
l'idée c'est de dire bon bah toutes les
toutes les données européennes resteront
sur le sol européen ça c'est une
première chose mais ça répond pas à la
question qui est ok c'est très bien
c'est depuis c'est stocké en Irlande
mais qu'est-ce qu'il me dit que à Pékin
des ingénieurs de Tik Tok n'ont pas la
possibilité d'appeler entre guillemets
ces serveurs pour regarder ce qu'il y a
dedans